you welcome to this video playing FM our
car here from Israel Jeff got a good
score against him and recently some song
game recently was kind of funky I don't
know why I don't I have this kind of
memory don't know what it was
okay let's see what we get got a Queens
gambit declined by a transposition
irises played in a very simple way here
not trying to do something crazy
okay I'll just take them it's their some
kind of tactic I don't get I don't think
so yeah but isn't this a bit better for
me with the pawns and with them he
pardoned but I must know I mean a six
this is what I'm trying to say a six and
B five those light squares a week I was
expecting he takes ok I'm not
threatening to take the pawn probably
because of rookie ideas sure I can do ad
ok I think I'm I'm I'm okay with just
playing with Knights
so let's trade and now go here 495
yeah attacks the pawn and 96 yeah this
96 but he has Queen c6 well that was a
very naive play by me
96 in 96 Queen c6 I can't play Queen a3
how ridiculous is that quite a bit yeah
it should be 754 should be 7 that's no
tactic okay wow that was bad the only
good thing is that this position is so
solid it's pretty difficult to to break
down
okay nights you form that's the only way
to play it in a somewhat more ambitious
way
all right that's it's a very simple way
to play it I thought you were trying to
keep the pawn there a little bit this is
this is equal at least I mean sorry I'm
not saying I'm better what I mean is I'm
glad that is equal and not not worse
anymore as it was
okay but if you put something on a dark
square I'm welcoming that but well it's
not a big deal anyway okay
then all the way there what can I cannot
be Russ here right this is interesting
maybe I can do something here he five
hooking up and King up I mean I'm not
the point is not going anywhere
hmm I stood still some kind of grow but
I have a hard time to guess anymore him
hmm okay g5 put puts it on a dark square
but still go over there I can try to
remove the night immediately difficult
to take the pawn with with the knight
the only way would be direct like d5
King G form
yeah I can definitely not not really
play for winning this position but I
don't see how
maybe I can maybe can go f5 trying to
put it on f6 time warning okay always
tempted to try to do something but this
might be just just a bad idea
yeah this was my idea
Knight e4 g5 attacking that I didn't
calculate this really can I he's just
too quick here right C 3 C 2 and stuff
there's no funky chick made or anything
neide f1 bishop c3 i have this check
though took me ages to find it this is
this is this is a very very funny way
check - all of a sudden win despawn give
ourselves very lucky him
very lucky I played it in a very that
was far to risk him far to risk him
right to afford the winner he cannot
protect both g5 and t6
that was very lucky and okay wait
check black forfeits on time oh yeah
that was that was insane what I did here
I really trying to try to do something
here in this position if I just stay I
think nothing's happening here like in
this position I can instead of if I for
example I can just stay and nothing
happens
yeah I think this is I mean maybe this
is still okay but it gets now against
very very risky okay my computer wants
to take 92 for drawing I am but okay the
computer actually gives this still as a
draw yeah okay maybe then it still felt
awfully risky but okay the computer sees
no window I was even thinking that just
might be an idea which is maybe crazy
because he will get some points there
but it's not okay that that that just
takes takes far too long SSS yeah see
yeah and here all of a sudden he's
losing what a joke
yeah that wasn't supposed to happen
really yeah I was surprised that he went
for this endgame but okay III was wrong
there I thought I might have some
chances but there's really nothing going
on with the bishop on before I can never
really approached this pawn in any any
sensible way
and then yeah nothing's really nothing's
really going on yeah lucky win there
thanks for watching